MARCUS ADAMS: Hi.
I'm Marcus Adams.
I work in Merck's Pharmaceutical
Manufacturing Division
as part of the Digital Proactive
Process Analytics Group.
This is our mascot, Rex.
See, like many things for
our prehistoric friend,
we were finding that the data--
we could see it, but it was
often just out of reach.
And that made us sad.
Now, we work to get
that data into the hands
of our scientists and
engineers at our manufacturing
sites around the world.
I am incredibly honored
to be here with you today.
I've had the privilege of
attending RStudio::conf
in the past, and I've always
found it to be an incredibly
enriching experience.
You get to hear about
exciting new ways
people are using the R language.
You get to have
great conversations
with wonderful members
of the R community.
And you get to take bets on
who will have the longest
line at the book signing event.
Hint-- in 2020, it was
not Hadley Wickham.
Unfortunately, I can't help
you with any of these things.
In fact, I'm about
to show you possibly
the world's most
boring shiny app.
But it is a shiny
app in production.
Here it is.
Text input box,
paste in our search,
could have uploaded it--
too fancy.
Lock it.
Check the syntax.
Great.
Click a button,
and wait some more.
I could sing for you,
but my go-to karaoke song
is Rap God, which
is six minutes.
And we shouldn't wait that long.
Great.
It's done.
Click a button,
download the PDF.
Here it is.
Here's our report.
Here's our table of
contents, quality attributes.
Skip to the first one.
It's our control chart, some
run rules, summary statistics,
and histograms.
Look at the distributions before
and after a process change.
And I know-- why am
I showing you this?
This R Markdown 101.
Creating a PDF report?
Are you kidding me?
That's not what's
important for us.
What was important
for us was that this
is saving tens of thousands
of hours each year,
the equivalent of millions
of dollars in productivity.
More important is that
engineers and scientists can now
use those hours for much
higher value activities
instead of just doing rote
data pulls and visualization.
Most importantly, this
is what our sites needed.
When we went out to one of our
largest manufacturing sites
in Singapore, they
told us, "We can't even
think of supporting an
advanced analytics project.
We need to get resources off of
required activities like CPV."
CPV is a Continuous
Process Verification
report you just saw.
And that report
is considered GMP.
If you're not from
pharma, that means
it adheres to Good
Manufacturing Practices.
In other words, this is the
kind of data and reporting
that we would submit to the FDA
and other regulatory agencies
around the world.
This is the kind
of data and reports
we would use to make
release decisions that
can have impact on millions
of patients around the world.
And so when we think about
this, we think production.
We think production plus
high level of regulations.
When the features may be a
few, and it may seem boring,
it's sort of like a
transformer, though.
There's more than meets the eye.
And Fred Brooks, in his
iconic Mythical Man-Month,
he describes this.
He says there's this tar pit.
And you start out with a program
in the upper left-hand corner.
And this is your core features.
This is what you crank
out in a weekend.
But this is not what you
deliver to your end users.
If you to make a
programming system,
integrate that with databases,
your authentication server--
that's going to take
three times as much work.
And if you want to make
it a programming product,
document it, test
it, generalize it--
that's also going to take
three times as much work.
And then if you want to move
to a programming systems
product, what we might
consider a production app--
that's going to take nine
times the amount of work.
So your original
program, that one ninth--
that one ninth-- that's just
your recurrent neural network.
That's only such a small
part of the end application.
The other 89% is what
it takes to create
a reliable, secure,
and maintainable app
in a production environment.
Now if you're not
an app developer,
or you don't come from a
computer science background,
you might not be familiar with
the bulk of what it takes.
We certainly weren't.
We're just a bunch of chemists
and chemical engineers.
And we're not the exception.
In fact, a Burtch Works study
in 2019 found that only 21%
of data scientists come from
a computer science background.
The rest of us--
we come from places like
statistics, business,
economics, or the
natural sciences.
Now, in true Pareto
fashion, luckily, that 21%
has done a lot of
heavy lifting for us.
And for us to get
to a production app,
we had to learn a lot of things.
But I don't have time
to share all those.
Instead, I'm just going to share
three of them with you today.
First, no excuses.
Code like a team.
Before this, a lot of
our scripts and apps,
we were able to
develop by ourselves.
They were small enough,
we could handle that.
But when you multiply
your workload by 9x,
you're going to need some help.
And when you're
working with others,
it's really good to
remember a golden rule.
Coding with others, it's
sort of like when people
come to visit your house.
You got to clean up
and put on real pants.
And first and foremost, you're
going to use version control.
And you may have
heard of Git before.
You may have seen it
with packages on CRAN
where the source code is.
But I think what doesn't
get enough attention is
the workflow in the
branching strategies.
You don't want to be
working on a single branch
because I guarantee
you, if you do,
somebody will make a commit
that will break the code.
And it will be 5 minutes before
you're supposed to give a demo.
Now there's many options.
But for us, we went
with a modified Gitflow.
And this means, at
the very low level,
we have feature branches.
And this is where we're
doing a lot of the work.
We're doing the
experimentations.
Things can break, and that's
fine because they're isolated.
But then, we merge them back
into our development branch.
This is the functioning
application.
This is our working
copy of the app.
And as we test and develop
that more, and it's ready,
we then merge that
into our master branch.
And that master branch is what
gets deployed into production.
And to get there, you
have to document, test,
and absolutely repeat.
So roxygen makes
it so easy to code
and have that documentation
right there in the same place.
And then you can render in a
much more even user-friendly
version.
Testing, that's also a
form of documentation.
That gives examples on
how to use your code.
And of course, both of
these together allows people
in the future to make changes
to your code much more rapidly
and know that they aren't
breaking core functionality.
And you may be used to or used
or familiar with unit testing.
This is the testthat,
the R unit, the tinytest.
But there's also even
more testing beyond that.
There's the UI testing.
Get users to actually
try your application out,
see if they can do
something useful with it.
Or automate some of
that with shinytest.
And then there's the one
that probably gets the least
attention-- load testing.
For us, a lot of our
scripts and applications
are running on local computers.
I mean, we have
one user at most.
But when you start
to put something
in a production
environment, you're
likely going to have
concurrent users.
And your application is going
to run differently with 10 users
than it will with one.
And it might run even more
different with 10,000 users.
You can absolutely scale
up to 10,000 users,
but you definitely want
to test it before you do.
And to get there,
you really want
to just take advantage of
R's natural coding structure.
Take advantage of the fact
that functions, packages,
and shiny modules
naturally lend itself
to the division of labor.
So one person can focus in
on the details of a function,
and it's abstracted for the
rest of everyone on the team.
They just need to know
how to call that function.
And that's exactly what we
did with our application.
At the top level, we have
the CPV reporting app.
And of course, that relies on
a bunch of common packages,
right--
dplyr, purrr,
and, of course, shiny.
But for us, we also created
four custom packages.
We have the one that connects
to our analytics platform--
MantisDBC.
We have cpvreportr that
actually compiles everything
into that PDF.
We have exceleratr that will
take the data and output it
in a reusable format
if people want
to do additional calculations.
And then we have ppxqc that does
our calculations in the report,
creates the control charts,
calculates the run rules,
creates histograms.
And the beauty of
this approach is
that now you've put all this
effort into creating this code,
you've industrialized
it, you've tested it,
you've documented it,
and you get to reuse it
for other applications.
As much as we have users
who use the reporting app,
we also have tons of data
scientists and R users
in our manufacturing
division that
are now much more
easily able to connect
to our analytics platform.
And I get emails probably
once a week about this.
And it's great that
they're able to reuse
something we already created.
Next, I want to talk
about environments.
See, US President
Woodrow Wilson once said,
"If you want to make enemies,
try to change something."
Data scientist
Marcus Adams says,
"If you want to make errors,
try to change environments."
Because when you talk about
a production environment,
that implies that there is also
a non-production environment.
And you may have more or
less than what's shown here.
You know, you have
dev, test, prod.
You may also have
a QC environment.
But the important
thing is you want
to separate from where you're
making changes to where people
are actually using your code.
You don't want to be
testing things out,
you know, tweaking things
here and there all the time.
When you're in a
production environment,
you have a certain
level of stability.
And as you move from
development, test,
to production, you want
things to be more controlled--
more tested, more stable.
People have to be able to
rely on this app to be there
and work in a consistent manner.
And I'll say something
that's a little contentious.
There are no production apps.
There are only apps in a
production environment.
And that production
environment, you
have to define its requirements.
And those requirements
come from how you're
going to use your application.
Now maybe you have
least requirements
and low expectations,
kind of like going
to a Carrot Top show.
But for us, who are
using it in a GMP manner,
we have to have things like
audit trails, timeouts,
tight change control.
My point is, though,
you want to get away
from this abstract mythical
land of production. Right?
This will lead you to
arguments about whether R
is ready for production.
And it moves you into
these very specifics
that you can start to articulate
exactly how are you going
to satisfy these requirements.
And you can take your
focus and make it
on industrialization and
generalization of your code.
And more importantly,
you can start
to tackle the seven circles
of R reproducibility hell.
I know what you're
asking, you're thinking,
why does Beelzebub have a
R tattoo across his chest?
I don't know.
I would assume the
dark lord would be more
closely associated with Python.
But maybe he lost a bet
to the archangel Gabriel.
I don't know.
But here we are.
And as Dante begins
his descent, he first
comes across the Code Version.
That is, your code you write
and is maintained by Git.
Or if not by Git, this is
your final version or version
final-final, final-final 2.0.
In that top-level
code itself, we
rely on certain
versions of packages.
These are your top
level packages.
Is it dplyr 1.0 or dplyr 0.8?
And each of these packages,
in turn, have dependencies.
And these are all the
names that you don't really
ever pay attention to
as they're scrolling
by when you install package--
BH, Farva, Scales.
But each of them also have
a version they require.
And those all run on top
of an R language version.
Are you using R 3.5 or R 4.0?
There were breaking
changes between those.
And moving down, there's
the runtime environment.
And I think this is the
most under-appreciated one.
So certainly, you want to manage
environment variables-- things
like proxy settings.
But you also have
to think, there is
differences between running
in an interactive mode
and running in batch.
And when you don't have
access to the console,
it makes a difference
whether you're
running your application
out of RStudio
or running it on
the Shiny Server.
And then from there, you also
have external dependencies.
These are your
systems libraries.
Think about trying
to install rJava.
You have to have that
JDK installed as well.
Or if you've ever
had the pleasure
of trying to install
LaTeX to make sure
you can generate
those PDF reports.
And then the innermost circle
is our operating system.
Code runs differently
between Windows and Mac,
and between Mac and Linux,
and Linux and Windows.
That's why some packages don't
work on all operating systems.
A simple example would be
that they use different path
separators--
a back slash or a forward slash.
But then there's also
more subtle things,
like how they render
visualizations.
And I can tell you that we
faced every one of these circles
in our journey.
But I'll give you
one example now.
See, here are some
wonderful control charts.
And on the left,
we have the version
in the development server.
And on the right, we have the
version on our test server--
identical code, but no
errors, no warnings,
and most importantly, no
resplendent dark green line
that shows the mean of the data.
Now I want to point out
that this is a dark space
green line.
And that's important
because officially, there
shouldn't be a space there.
However, we were using
this code for years
before we actually even deployed
it to the development server,
and it worked.
So you've got to
be asking yourself,
how does a single space pose
such an existential threat
to our application?
Well, like most things in
life, timing is critical.
You see, when you specify
version requirements
for your packages,
everything downstream of that
sits in this quantum
superpositions.
The actual versions
that will get installed
doesn't happen to actually
install those packages.
So our ppxqc package relied
on ggplot2, of course.
and that, in turn,
required scales.
Now before November 19, 2019,
that resolved to scales 1.0.0
That could handle
our dark space green.
After November 19, 2019,
it resolved to scales 1.1.0
And that changed how it
translated that string
into a numeric value
to represent that color
and inadvertently broke
backwards compatibility.
We just so happened to deploy
to test in late November, 2019.
Now we caught that because
we ran tests, like we should.
But I'll tell you,
packrat wasn't
sufficient to catch this.
We tried.
What we really need
here was CRAN snapshots,
either from Microsoft's
CRAN snapshots,
RStudio package manager, or
even internal CRAN snapshots.
And to give the cherry on
top of this and a testament
to really great
package maintainers,
this problem only
existed about a month.
By mid-January, this was solved.
And so the moral of the
story is don't deploy early.
Let the package maintainers
fix everything first.
Now lastly, I want
to say, if you
can't run your app without
direct intervention,
it was never an
app to start with.
Your app will suffer
the slings and arrows
of outrageous fortune.
And by that, I mean
crazy input you never
expected users to have.
Like, ...12 digits of
precision,... your code
has to be robust to survive
the thousand natural shocks
the app is heir to.
And it has to do it without
your direct intervention.
But just because you
can't directly intervene
doesn't mean the app can't
collect information for you.
First and foremost, log.
There's plenty of
programs out there
that help you with this--
futile.logger, log4r, logging.
It's one thing to log errors in
the crashes in the stack trace
when that happens, but
you also want context.
Your app is kinda like a kid too.
You don't want just your
teachers calling you
when something bad happens.
You want to know the
good things that happen.
You want to know how
people are using it.
What are they submitting?
What are the queries
they're looking for?
And you know what?
It's kind of like your child.
It really is because you
put a lot of work into it.
And so like a good child,
also make it call home.
Use things like Google
Analytics to let you know who
and where this
app is being used.
Google Analytics tags are fairly
simple to copy some JavaScript
into your UI code,
and then you get
to see all these analytics about
how your code is being used.
You can see peak volumes.
You can see what time of year
this application's being used.
Maybe you want to scale up
your production servers.
And lastly, you
may actually want
to have your application
adopt to its environment.
There's some great
packages out there
that allow you to do just this.
The config and secrets
package do just that.
In a simple example,
you may-- for us,
we needed to show a banner in
our dev and test environments
that said, this is
not for official use.
But more complex for us
was password management
between the environments.
You see, for us, each
of our environments,
we had a service account.
And that service
account had a password
that connected to a different
database for each environment.
And our dev
environment should not
have access to our production
environment database.
And our production environment
should not have access
to our dev database.
Furthermore, it was a
security requirement
that we could not store these
passwords in clear text.
And I'll say this,
that credentials
and secrets management
is such a deep topic.
I am, by no means,
an expert on it.
But I'll only share what we
did because that solution was
inspired by a hallway
conversation
I had with the R-Podcaster
himself, Eric Nantz,
at R/Pharma 2019.
When our client, the
UI, contacts our server,
we look at the URL requested,
specifically the subdomain.
And this is great
because we actually
have multiple production servers
sitting behind an Application
Load Balancer.
And so by looking
at that subdomain,
is it shiny dev, shiny
tests, or just shiny
for a production environment?
We can then use
the config package
to go grab the correct
parameters from a YAML file.
Specifically, for us, that is
the ID of the service account,
the database to which
we should connect,
and the name of the
secret in our vault
that holds the password.
See, we've encrypted those
passwords in the vault.
And with the server's
individual private SSH keys,
they can decrypt
that password and use
that to go grab the data
from the correct database.
And this is really
useful because we
can encrypt the password
and make a commit to our
Git repository.
And only a few developers
need to know those passwords.
And only those servers,
when we deploy them,
should be able to
access those passwords.
For rotating the passwords,
we just make a pull request
with the updated password,
and that can be deployed out
to the proper server.
And I get it.
Password management
is not exciting.
But deploying is.
It is totally worth it.
And I admit-- my
head jerks every time
I hear the word production
in a presentation title.
But getting there is not all
natural language processing
and random forest.
And hopefully, you realize by
now, actually, most of getting
there is not.
What I've talked about
today really only even
scratches the surface.
Just know, though, you
can use R and shiny
in a production environment.
We are not even
the first to do so.
Just last year, Heather
and Jacqueline Nolis
at RStudio::conf talked
about how T-Mobile does it.
We are just yet another
example of how you can do it.
And if you need to, namedrop.
We are a Fortune 500 company.
And we are using it for a very
important reporting process.
Look-- putting a shiny
app into production
is like playing the old
computer game, The Oregon Trail.
Now you're not
guaranteed to succeed.
It might not be pretty.
And it might be hard.
But it can be done.
Others have done it before you.
You just need to figure
out how to do it.
And of course, avoid dysentery.
But that's good advice,
even beyond developing
shiny applications.
And like those pioneers
crossing the Rocky Mountains,
we too have crossed
over, figured out how,
and reached the top of the
mountain of production.
And as we look out
over this vista,
I'll leave you with these words.
You can't always
code what you want,
but if you build
sometimes you might just
find you code what you need.
Thank you for your time.
I hope you got something
you needed from this talk.
And I hope you enjoy the
rest of the conference.
Thank you.